now for the perfect way to ease yourself
into the day it's my guide to brunches
brunch is simply a delicious combination
of breakfast and lunch and for me it's
all about getting up late and having a
wonderful lazy start to the weekend with
fantastic food more exciting than
breakfast and a lot more job to cook
brunch is ideal for sharing first up my
simple and delicious frittata eggs are
great they are so versatile and once
you've mastered how to cook them trust
me
the door then opens to a wide range of
delicious options this is like a triple
omelet but a lot more ingredients and a
normal mesh first start off with some
lovely smoked bacon and slice the bacon
bacon in those salts took the pepper
start off on a high heat get that bacon
really nice and crispy otherwise you
just spoil the bacon and it's got that
soft unpleasant texture and the frittata
turn down the gas and now start adding
your veg roughly chop a red pepper and
add it to the pan
the peppers and the bacon take the
longest of it always got it going first
now so to them off and the peppers have
been cooked now from that sort of
rendered fat from the bacon and then the
spring onions just bunch them up slice
them I want them on an angle so they
come like little green diamonds spring
onions in now for the eggs cracking the
eggs that size pan seven or eight eggs
I'll fill it right to the very top I'm
more importantly when I turn this out I
want it like a gas oh nice and thick so
slice through and see what wonderful
heads
[Music]
on a season the eggs with some Parmesan
cheese be quite generous because it adds
a really nice saltiness fresh ground
pepper and then whisk whisk up those
eggs nicely then have P to the pan and
to give the dish a wonderful aromatic
freshness some fragrant of chopped basil
roughly cuz I want to see those flecks
of green going in weight looking
charming and how many times have you see
you know a dull omelet for Tartars in my
mind really help encapsulate the magic
of having savory eggs cook beautifully
but with texture now just before we had
the eggs I've got this beautiful little
ghost shoes and it's strong and powerful
so I want to slice it into little chunks
and then just have it top it around I
want to discover these little pockets of
creamy goat cheese now slowly add the
eggs
[Music]
fill that right up a spoon now just let
all that hair go down to the bottom
bring it back up to the boil and sort of
clean round the sides and then some of
this delicious salty creamy ghost cheese
over the top now I want it now looking
like a a perfect slice cheese on toast
nice now from there turn the grill on
for four to five minutes
[Music]
mmm now just looking at that delicious
take a little paring knife and just make
sure it's release on the sides just take
your panel tab that will hopefully
release the frittata from the bottom of
the pan now bought over the pan turn
that gently just shake say a little
prayer licked off
[Music]
now from there on there it's there look
now slice through
you can see how soft and creamy that is
in the center mat goat cheese are just
melting almost like a little sauce
inside so exciting but more importantly
it's so easy to do it's got texture it's
got creaminess and that for me will beat
any omelet for brunch serve with a stack
of hot buttered toast and a steaming pot
of coffee this easy patata turns the
humble egg into the perfect dish for
kicking off the weekend
[Music]
eggs are really versatile protein-packed
and delicious here are three more of my
favorite recipes to give your brunches a
tasty twist first up north african eggs
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan and fry
finely chopped onions and red and green
peppers then chop garlic and chilli and
cook until softened
Chili's weren't Brittany with eggs given
the dish a lovely hot kick next add
fresh chopped tomatoes then cumin seeds
and fry until the seeds are fragrant and
the tomatoes are lovely and soft season
next make wells in your spicy sauce and
crack in your eggs
then cover them cook on a low heat for
five minutes so the whites are set and
the yolks are still lovely and runny to
finish sliced spring onions and
coriander and simply sprinkle over
fresh spicy and deliciously different
easy North African eggs ready in under
20 minutes and this worth getting up
late for next eggs made super indulgence
for brunch cheese souffle with three
cheese's
[Music]
mix together flour sugar baking powder
and seasoned make a well in the center
then simply beat six eggs together pour
into the well to whisk into the flour
then whisk in milk making the mixture
lovely and light next add the three
cheese's cottage cheese grated Monterey
Jack or cheddar and cream cheese and
then for extra richness knobs of butter
then butter a baking dish and pour in
your rich cheesy cheats soufflé mix now
put in a medium oven and bake for 40
minutes until bridge golden and puff to
perfection a stunning fuss-free souffle
that's ideal for brunch
[Music]
my next easy egg dish is a salty and
succulent prawn and feta omelet
pour olive oil into a hot pan add
chopped tomatoes
spring onions and fry season next add
cooked prawns and a sprinkle of chili
flakes to give it a lovely kick of heat
cook through and set aside next beat
four eggs add olive oil to your frying
pan and pour in the eggs
sprinkle home freshly chopped oregano
which works brilliantly with eggs then
spoon over the spicy prawns crumble over
creamy feta cheese and Grill for a
couple of minutes
this is eggs to the nth degree packed
with different tastes textures and
flavors all working wonderfully together
perfect one super versatile ingredient
free mouth-wateringly different recipes
brunch has never been better
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips
first up red pepper as you've seen great
for frittata and North African eggs but
you need to know how to cut them
properly absolutely love these peppers
now
they have the most amazing sweet
delicious flavor with a really nice
crunchy texture and the most exciting
thing about the peppers is that they're
just as delicious raw or cooked to
identify the perfect pepper must be
smooth and firm and not a wrinkle in
sight now how to cut the perfect pepper
stalk off pepper down and get the knife
start from the top and slice all the way
around basically we're gonna be slicing
around the seeds look no fapping around
but this is a perfect Christmas tree of
seeds and yam got the mess all over your
board and more importantly is twice as
quick discard that now we're gonna cut
it into a julienne flatten the pepper
skin side down onto the board because
it's a lot easier just slice through the
pepper and just lift the knife up and
down and basically julienne is a chef's
word for strips these are absolutely
perfect for a so chain and that's what
we're looking for they're crunchy
delicious and more importantly no seeds
beautiful
many great brunch recipes start with a
delicious fresh egg my tried and tested
wait is telling that egg is fresh is to
simply place it into a bowl of cold
water our fresh egg will sink and a
stale one will float
if a small piece of shell goes into the
bowl when you're cracking eggs my tip
for removing it is to simply use a
larger piece to fish it out it works
like magic for prize-winning fried eggs
fry them in oil adding a tablespoon of
water then cover the water steams the
top of the egg to perfection
towstee bagels are brilliant for brunch
my tip to make sure you always have them
on hand is to stock up your freezer but
make sure you slice them first that way
you can pop them straight into your
toaster
this is my ultimate cookery course 800
recipes to stake your life on I'm about
to show you my recipe for delicious
spicy pancakes tuck it underneath that
put it back and roll but first here's my
guide to find beautiful eggs knowledge
is crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients are from and how they
produce the better in my home kitchen I
use eggs in abundance they are so
versatile and get in to grips with them
or make your cooking sink your chickens
with a decade of experience under her
belt Helen from Harris farm in Harper
Chur is a real egghead and are some
valuable tips to share the hens we keep
are designed to lay probably 300 350
eggs a year free-range means that the
bird must have access to the outside at
all times chickens love grass they pick
it whatever's on the ground and it makes
the eggs a lovely rich golden color and
the flavor is tremendous hell if an egg
is really fresh crack it open put it on
a dish and you will see that it sits up
really quite high and the white is
really nice and tight around the side
the yolk there's a vast range of eggs
out there to experiment with
wasting to what you know try driving up
your brunches with something different
this is a band Meg they are miniature
chickens the yolks are quite large
compared to the whites of the egg and
they're absolutely delicious making
scrambled eggs out of them because
they're much more creamier all together
than so chickens egg this is the Ducks
egg
these ones are sort of white color but
they can be sort of creamy greeny colors
compared to chicken eggs
the Ducks yolk is richer and creamier
and the white is fluffier when whisk
which is why they're so incredible for
bacon this is the goose egg this is
quite a large egg it's probably
equivalent to three chicken eggs
the geese literally lay for about 12
weeks from my few geese we've had about
a hundred and twenty eight
they're amazing layers but just for the
very short season the amazing thing is
the color of the yolks of these they are
usually quite orange the geese don't
actually eat anything other than grass
they are just grazes and that makes a
huge difference to the color of the yolk
another fantastic egg is the quail egg
tiny but incredibly tasty they only take
a minute to soft boil and are delicious
dipped in celery salt if you've got a
big appetite or you make it a brunch for
a big group of friends you could try the
giant rare egg from South America the
equivalent of 10 hen eggs they're great
scrambled or as a massive omelet another
interesting option is the pheasant egg
small but rich in flavor
they're perfect for homemade Scotch eggs
or hard-boiled in a salad keep eggs new
fridge but ideally when you go to use
them take them out bring them up to room
temperature because you'll find that
they will cook better just make sure
that there's no cracks in them and then
you'll be assured that they're nice
healthy tasting eggs
[Music]
brunch should be a laid-back affair and
a treat so the dishes need to be easy to
cook but never boring my next recipe
takes the humble pancake to a whole new
level of flavor and excitement soft
fiery and irresistible of spicy pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination when it
comes to brunches you don't have to
stick to the old standbys these
delicious spicy pancakes are a really
great alternative but more importantly
so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin it's a
dry roast basically non-stick pan just a
touch of seasoning the salt helps to dry
out the kyumin's even more and then
fresh ginger slice um nice and thinly
stack it back up and then just slice
nice little thin slices in there and
then keep that bunched up shank your
chili
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot now garlic nice now add
olive oil to your toasted cumin seeds
and in with a garlic ginger and chili
lovely it feels strange when you talk
about garlic for breakfast but the time
I spent in India everybody was eating
something savory for breakfast it was
extraordinary into your bowl and set
aside next the pancake filling and olive
oil to a hot pan mustard seeds in now
they'll start dancing the minute I hit
the pan
then finally slice an onion onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and a good color and instant
change leftover potatoes just slice them
smell is incredible take this in now
spread the potatoes across the pan while
the potatoes stain I want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge season those
potatoes it really helped to bring out
spice beautifully
they're ready turn off the gas and let
me sit there and absorb all those
flavors back to the pancake batter add
plain flour to your cooled garlic chili
ginger and cumin seeds touch salt and
pepper nothing worse than the bland
pancake one whole egg milk hold the jug
one hand and whisk your secrets they
have an really nice smooth paste
but whisking that egg first and brings
it together and then your milking
then all the Milken is any gonna get a
lumpy pancake mix if you put less milk
in it really helps it not going lumpy
look at that
okay the secret for me is to have a nice
thin mix now just a little teaspoon of
oil that helps to bring a nice crispy
edge to the mixture now that's the
texture pan on the large of the pan the
better it helps to create a nice thin
even surface I want that mix gone all
the way around the pan before you put
the mixture into the pan make sure you
give your pancake mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil get that nice whisk
with one hand pan to the mix in one and
a half ladles and then roll it round
which is really nice and thin I want to
see the ginger the garlic that's what
I'm looking for in there now back onto
the heat only starts to remove from the
bottom of the pan and lifts itself up
once it's cooked these little bubbles
confirm those just dance and lift off
the pan and it will shake that releases
it and then just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the condoms
of tossing then use a spatula and turn
it over now that's exactly what I want
that nice sort of crisp edge around the
side the color on the pancake is so
important
now roll around and just let it slide
out usually
if now the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes you just sort of have
a really nice imaginary line and then
just very carefully roll that nice
typing
tuck it underneath there put it back and
roll
usually the delicious pancakes are ready
to eat but with a simple dipping sauce
there'll be a real treat just mix
chopped coriander with natural yoghurt
that's pretty nice cooling agent sit
that on the site and that for me is a
great brunch delicious spicy pancakes
amazing follow my ultimate cookery
course bursting with valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking